[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis vraiment
il commence à faire froid dans le ciel
alors nounours tu descends voir nicolas
et pimprenelle weepu trop du matage on
soit en les offrant ce qu'ils sont
précieux métal et un siècle à nos il y
avait du clouët était dans ses messages
marrant c d of people avec des balances
sur les noms des défunts
nicolas ouais c'est ça des planques et
du messieurs espagnole avec une même
teinté rongeurs nous des jongleurs n'est
que la peau du dos je la monte
changement qu'est ce qu'il faisait ce
jour genève et pécs aux anneaux il
rattrapait tous des ballons des cerceaux
la dame comme ça faut là où c'est très
bien les enfants ça suffise à 30 et je
vais vous montrer comment ils font
lèvres et joues oncle les furgler
chinois
il me faut des bâtons et des astuces
c'étaient les impôts
[Musique]
tc jean gleizes reçu le foot confrontent
en
[Musique]
et maintenant j'ai besoin de silence
parce que je vais exécuter devant vous
messieurs dames est extrêmement
difficile
l artiste a besoin de se concentrer
vas-y concentrent 90 ch et le bâton
nacion
je m'en vais faire tourner cette
bestiole sur les bunds se portent
attention atteint siens
walt où se déroula je vais recommencer
attention je me concentre à temps on est
bien concentré prêt
réduits ou pauvreté paquereau oui allons
les enfants oui sinon les petits matches
donne ça va tu as goûté et voilà on est
cochée ben niang lors maniement gunino
ce bus le petit your auto beau tellement
prenant à nicolas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous aussi les petits enfants embrasser
vite vos parents et allez vite vous
coucher en route nounours
bonne nuit à demain
à tout haut
[Musique]